a graph data structure is a non-linear
data structure consisting of vertices
and edges they're used to solve many
real world problems and are commonly
needed to solve coding challenges Harris
from coding cleverly teaches this graph
course using Java Harris is extremely
knowledgeable in algorithms and data
structures
hey there everyone this is coding
cleverly and today we're going to be
talking about the graph data structure
we're going to talk about how it works
how it's constructed and all the
important stuff we need to know about it
the first thing I did was create three
different files in the same directory
here I have graph.java and then we have
vertex.java and we also have Edge dot
Java and what I'm going to do now is I'm
going to actually write some code and
then I'm going to try to Interlink these
all three files because this Edge this
vertex and this graph are going to be
used together to create our graph data
structure before talking about graphs I
want to talk about the graph traversals
are many ways to Traverse a graph but
you will focus on three methods depth
first search breadth first search and
dijkstra's algorithm these traversal
methods are core algorithms for
searching a graph now what are graphs
graphs are the ideal data structure for
modeling networks making them an
essential part of your data structure
toolkit they are made up of nodes or
vertices which hold data and edges which
connect two vertices
a Vertex is a single node now all of
this will be explained through the
diagram here's a sample of a graph that
I created these circles everywhere are
actually vertices and they're holding
data and edges which connect two
vertices so these lines over here are
known as edges these things now I want
to give an example consider a map of
your neighborhood as a graph we could
represent bus stops as vertices and bus
routes between stops as edges so how
about the internet web pages can be
thought of as vertices and the
hyperlinks that connect them as edges
real world relationships represent as
graphs are numerous making them an
important concept to grasp the graph
which you could see over here is
actually representing a social network
people are vertices and edges are
friendships so these lines are
friendships these circles are the people
Peter Cody and Jordan are all friends
Peter and Cody are friends and the same
goes for Cody and Peter Peter and Jordan
are also friends and Jordan all and
Peter are friends as well so this
bi-directional pattern is also existing
here Jordan Cody are friends and Cody
and Jordan are friends one other thing
that we see here is this thing which is
Caleb and Alex now these are friends but
these are not linked with these people
over here interesting a path is made up
of vertices connected by any number of
intermediate edges from Peter to Cody
the paths could be Peter to Jordan to
Cody or Peter to Cody there is no way
between Peter and Caleb a graph is
disconnected when no path exists between
two vertices so this here is a
disconnected graph because not all of
these vertices are connected with each
other it's impossible to reach here so
this is the reason why this graph is a
disconnected graph all right so now
let's map out this concept in our code
now what we want to do is we want to
create a graph class that could be
flexible enough to support directed
undirected weighted and unweighted
graphs now
the difference between a directed and
undirected graph is that for directed
graphs which is so this is an undirected
disconnected graph because there's no
link here and you can't reach here so
this is disconnected the reason why it's
undirected is the reason that both of
these paths are like bi-directional so
over here Peter and Jordan is Peter's
friends to Jordan and also Jordan's
friends to Peter so this is
bi-directional so and this is undirected
if it's directed it would have arrows
here so it would point that Peter is
only friends to Jordan but Jordan
doesn't like him back and Jordan is
friends to Cody and Cody doesn't like
him back so something like that is going
to be directed in case of weighted
graphs you'd have weights on top of each
so I know it doesn't make sense over
here but if we had like stop bus stops
and then their
um routes it would have been easier and
easy to map out but here if I say Peter
and then Jordan it takes like
um let's say five
so it's something like this and then we
have um
over here we have let's say 10.
and over here let's say it's 12. so over
here now we got weights on top of the
edges
and these are just going to indicate the
number or the expense that we're gonna
take here so Peter
um I know it's not a good example like I
said that we could have done with uh bus
stops and routes but here we're taking
Peter his friends with Jordan and I
don't say five times uh he he likes him
five times this Jordan likes Cody 10
times and Cody likes Peter 12 times I'm
not sure if that was a good example but
uh you you got my point there something
like that it with which Associates um
the numbers as they're expenses with
this in mind we will create our graph
with the following requirements a Vertex
can store any data so these are circles
a Vertex maintains a list of connections
to other vertices represented by a list
of edge instances so we're gonna have a
Vertex we're gonna also have its list to
connect other ones so those are going to
be called as these vertices and they're
going to be linked through the edges so
here we have Peter but friends are
Jordan and Cody right so we're gonna
have to put that in some kind of
structure here so it's going to be in a
list of edges so they're going to be
represented by a list of edge instances
a Vertex can add and remove edges going
to another vertex
a graph stores all of this all of its
vertices represented by a list of vertex
instances so all of these vertices you
see are just going to be stored in that
graph structure a graph knows if it is
directed or undirected like I said this
is undirected and if you had some kind
of Direction it would have been directed
a graph can add and remove its own
vertices graph can add and remove edges
between stored vertices with all of that
out of the way let's write the code so
to keep the concepts grounded in a real
world application
we'll build a transportation network of
bus stops as we go what I want to do
first thing is actually look into my
vertex class and because I know this is
the circle which has the data and it's
also going to have the edges so we're
going to start from this one here we're
gonna go into this class vertex here
and we're just going to create some
instance variables
so the first thing that I am saying is
the private string
data
the second thing that comes to the mind
is
private arraylist
because we want to store the edges right
so we say arraylist we put the type of
the arraylist here so we're going to
store edges
so it's an arraylist of edges and we're
going to call this as edges
all right so now we're done with that
let's add a Constructor here we're going
to say public and we're going to say
vertex
here we're going to have a string
and we'll say input data
the data that the user will provide
and then for that we'll take the class
variable is equal to the input parameter
and then we have this dot edges
which is uh the edges and that would
equal to the new array list
and here we want
um the edge
and we also want this so
here we instantiated the array list
which was this edges one now I know this
is giving us problems because it's not
allowing us to have this so let's just
import this import java.util.arraylist
and the errors are gone here we have a
Vertex Constructor that assigns the data
with the input data and also
instantiates the edges list with a new
arraylist of type Edge
to see these edges in live action right
the other thing that I want to go
through with this is that I'm going to
create this as a directed graph so
there's going to be arrows here a method
called public
void
um add edge
and over here we're gonna add in the
vertex
and vertex
and
integer
wait
all right so now that this is done and
we just created this uh Constructor for
this I mean know the instance variables
let's move on to edge.java and create
the instance variables for here and then
after that we're gonna go back to this
vertex.java and finish it up one thing I
want to make clear here is that I'm
going to create a directed graph it's
going to be the ones that have the
arrows it's not going to be the
bi-directional ones which would go both
ways it's just going to be one one stop
to the other stop right it's a bus stop
so I don't want to go backwards so in
this case it's just a directed graph
um what we're going to do here is for
the edge like I said it's just a line
where you see in the graphical
representation but here I'm gonna have
to try to map it out in code so I'm
going to have the start vertex where
it's coming from and where it's going to
so pry vit private vertex
and then we have the end
and over here we want to wait we're also
going to create this as a weighted graph
that will have a cost for how much uh
expense will it take to move from one
place to another remember those numbers
which were on top of those lines so
that's the weight here so it's going to
be a weighted graph as well so I'm going
to put up weight in here as well and
it's going to be called integer
and I'm going to say w i g h t I'm gonna
put a integer weight and notice I'm
using integer and not int it's the
reason the reason is that if I don't
want to put anything I could just type
in null and it would allow me to just uh
like pass it on with no reason and if I
had an integer I'd pass in something
like minus one all right so now over
here we have a Constructor and I would
say public Edge
and let's create the Constructor here so
the vertex
and I'll say the start vertex so I'll
call it as the start B the vertex
and we have n vertex so we have Envy
we have the integer
and we call it as the input weight
so there you go
so we got the start vertex the N vertex
and the input weight
that we're going to ask the user for
so remember this is just a an edge that
we are creating as a user so
the class variable this dot star will
equal to the start vertex in which will
be passed in as an input parameter
the same thing goes for
um the disk dot end
and it will equal to the end vertex I
would say end vertex
and we have the weight so we say this
Dot
w-e-i-g-h-t and we equal that to the
input
w e i g h t there you go so now we're
done with this and let's just add in
some other helper methods so I'm going
to be adding some helper methods along
with this and I'm just going to be copy
pasting this so here these are the
public vertex get start and it's just
going to return the start vertex the
public start vertex get end will return
the end vertex of the um you know the
edge within the edge and the integer
Gateway will just return the weight
okay so that was cool let's go back to
the vertex.java file and just make some
methods here as well so um for the
vertex.java remember like I said we
wanted to create a function that will
allow us to add some edges right we're
not giving the
we're adding a layer of abstraction here
and we're allowing the method over here
will just add edges for us so what I can
do here is I could say a public
and I'd say void add e d so e add EDG so
add edge and if we want to add an edge
to a Vertex so remember the current
vertex is already in the context so this
will be the end vertex so I'll just pass
in the N vertex here and also the weight
if you want to give it some kind of
weight remember I said weight is
optional
um if you don't want to give it will be
assigned as null to do something like
that
first of all I'm gonna have
um the call to this so I'm gonna say
this dot edges edges because it exists
and edges over here and then there is a
function that was called add for the um
arraylist because edges is an array list
and we just add in a new Ed GE and we
call in the Constructor so this
Constructor will pass in the this it
will get the edges um and the vertex so
it's going to be n vertex
and will also be the weight of the edge
so all of this will be mapped in here so
this is our um add edge and it's going
to add some edges here all right so now
uh we're gonna have to create the remove
edge here so we're going to say public
and I'm going to say void
um remove
e d g e and we have um vertex
and we have
um n vertex
and over here we have
the um this dot Edge edges dot remove
D and the method for this is um since
it's uh I just is an arraylist so remove
if will allow us to add a predicate and
remove all of the elements of this
collection that satisfy the given
predicate errors at runtime exceptions
thrown during iteration or by the
predicate are relayed to the caller
parameter here is a predicate and here
you can read it it says filter up
predicate which returns true for
elements to be removed and I'm going to
add that predicate here so
over here I'm gonna add in
um so I want to remove that vertex so
here I'm saying remove edge right and
I'm in that vertex um so I'm in the
vertex.java and I want to remove that
edge that uh was passed in as this one
so n vertex right I want to remove that
edge from here so I would say uh edges
dot remove if now say I'll remove that
kind of edge all right and then we put
this Arrow bracket so this is the arrow
sign I'm going to say edges
um and then we say get end because
um we're getting actually
two things here the edges are having two
um places one is the first and the
second is the end so you could see in
the code over here we have the start and
the end so the edge has two things and
what we want is the end so that's why we
are getting the second one
and that's going to be over there so
um that'll get end
and then we say dot equals so we say if
that equals to the vertex that we passed
in here I'm just going to copy that and
paste it here
and if that equals then just remove that
from there so
um we just need a semicolon here
if I could get a semicolon all right
and that should solve our problem here
so it's just going to remove that n
vertex that we passed in as an input
parameter and it's going to look at this
edges dot remove if and it's going to
pass in this predicate logic that says
find that edge which has the end of
vertex equal to the N vertex that was
passed in pretty easy okay so now we're
gonna add in some other helper methods
I'm going to copy paste this as well so
I'll just paste it here
so the first thing uh let me just first
zoom out and show you what I've done
here we have this remove edge and we
have the add edge perfect over here we
have this get data method it's a string
return type and it's just going to get
the data for the vertex pretty easy
straightforward and the arraylist edge
so this is the return type and it's
saying get edges so it's just going to
return the
um the edges that the certain vertex has
so it's just going to return the list of
it this dot edges all right now over
here we have a public void print Boolean
show weight so over here we have this uh
print method that's just gonna allow us
to visualize our implementation and it's
just going to show us how the graph is
looking like inside of our structure so
it's pretty
um easy you don't need to go into detail
for this and if you want to write this
down uh you can pause the video and
start typing this in we're done with the
edge.java and we're also done now with
the vertex.java in fact I don't even
need this main method here so I'm just
going to remove that here and now we
just have this so the vertex edge.java
and the
vertex.java are done let's go to the
graph.java the main thing the main boss
so over here we're just gonna add in the
following things remember like I said a
graph is a list of vertices that's
exactly what we want to do here so I'm
going to say private
and I'm going to say array list and I'm
going to put in the type here the type
for this is vertex because we're putting
in vertices and we're going to pass in
vertices like this is the name now we
also have our type which I specified
that there could be different kinds and
my graph will be a weighted graph so I'm
just gonna put in is weighted Boolean
variable
I'm also going to put is
directed
[Applause]
Boolean variable and this is just going
to tell me if the graph is directed with
arrows or if it's um unidirectional or
bi-directional so that's that's the
thing let's create the Constructor for
the graph and we'll just say public
graph
graph and then we'll just pass in
Boolean
and we'll say
um input
is weighted so the the things that are
uh passed in will be determined by the
user
and pull Boolean input
is directed
so we're done with this
and here we're going to have the this
dot vertices
and we're going to say new array
list
[Applause]
and we're just gonna pass in so over
here we have graph and then we have
Boolean input is weighted and then we
have uh input is directed so like I said
we have to first initialize the vertices
arraylist so I'll just say new arraylist
vertex put the round brackets and then
the semicolon this will initialize our
vertex
uh this will initialize our vertices
list and for the weighted thing so we
can say is w e
weighted is equal to and we say input is
um weighted so
w-e-i-g-h-t for the other one which is
directed so is directed is equal to
input is directed There you go
cool so now this um is created and yeah
I have to import the array list as well
so just import that as well
now let's create some methods and the
important methods that we want to do
here is that we want to create a method
that will allow us to add vertex add
some vertices to our array list and the
name for that will be self-explanatory
it's called vertex and that's a return
type so it's going to be called add
vertex
the data that will be passed in was as a
string and over here we'll say vertex
and we'll say new vertex
and over here we're just gonna create a
new vertex here so we'll say new vertex
and we'll pass in the data that was
passed in
and over here we're gonna
put that inside of our list so we'll say
this Dot vertices.add and we put the new
vertex
semi call in
and then we have the return new
vertex
cool so we're done with this that's the
advertex method and it just returns us
the vertex so we'll have to assign it to
a variable in the main methods so now
we're going to create the public
um void
add edge method
and this will allow us to pass in the
vertex vertex one
the vertex
vertex two so this is the start and the
end vertex and the
um integer way like I said I wanted to
create a level of abstraction here so
I'm allowing our graph to have the uh
add edge of functionality as well so
over here it's pretty straightforward if
I said um
if the thing is weighted then uh there's
gonna be
um no wait for this because I passed an
integer weight and I I'll have to first
check the Boolean variable here so if I
say is weighted
um not directed but is w-e-i-g-h-t now
if the weighted was false then uh so it
says if weighted is false right
so we'll just say
um the weight
that was passing it will be assigned as
null
all right
and
if it's not false meaning if the thing
is weighted thing so we'll say vertex
one dot add edge and over here we're
actually adding the vertex to
and here the weight will be passed in as
well and this is the add edge method
that's from the vertex class here so the
vertex add edge this one
now over here we want to actually add in
the other thing around as well because
we need um bi-directional and
um unidirectional so if it's
undirected then both right and if it's
directed then just one so I'll say if
it's not directed then both so this Dot
uh is directed if it's not directed
then we'll have the
um
vertex
vertex 2 dot add vertex
or yeah so vertex 2. add edge here we're
gonna add the edge and we're gonna say
vertex one
and we're also gonna put in the uh
weight over here as well
and there you go similar to how we
created the add edge method we now need
to create the remove edge method so just
go here a little down and let's add the
remove edge method so we're just right
like I said I'm giving the
the power to the user to do all of this
so and the user doesn't even have to
know how the vertex Java or edge.java
works
so that's the layer of abstraction that
we're creating here remove edge
and over here we're gonna pass in the
vertex
and we'll say vertex
so to remove the edge you'll have to
need you'll need the vertex one
you'll also need the vertex
two
now to remove it it's pretty simple we
say vertex one dot remove this is the
method
um that was there so remove edge and it
takes another vertex and we have the N
vertex here but we're just going to pass
in the vertex too and there you go and
then uh like I said we have to check if
it's not directed if it's bi-directional
then we have to remove the other way
around as well so I'll say if
um this dot is directed so if it's
undirected right so if it's
bi-directional then we'll have to move
the other way around as well using
vertex 2. remove edge and we put in the
vertex one
okay so that was pretty much it with the
remove edge now we have um some other
methods like remove vertex so I'll just
add in them remove vertex quickly over
here void
um remove
vertex
and for the remove vertex we have the
vertex that's passed in as like this
and what we're gonna do is we're gonna
say this dot vertices which is the list
that is existing here in this class this
instance variable and we're going to use
the remove method that's provided by the
array list and we're just going to
remove the vertex that you just asked
for right so that's just going to be
removed here now to save some time I'm
just pasting some helper methods that we
also need here so I'll just paste that
in and let's see how it looks like so
here we have the get vertices the remove
vertex the get vertices method it just
Returns the list is weighted
um is directed so that the last thing
what we did was this one which was
remove the vertex and then after that
this one is just a get vertices it's
just going to return the array list
vertex so the whatever the arraylist is
it's going to return all the vertices
here inside of that current um graph
public Boolean is weighted will return
if the graph is weighted or not
and Boolean is director will turn if
it's directed or not
public vertex get vertex by value
passing a value and it will Loop through
this um four Condition it's going to go
vertex so you pass in a string value and
you're trying to look for that vertex
for that kind of value so let's say I
have a stop in um New Jersey let's say
Jersey City I'm looking for Jersey City
stop for my bus you know bus route so in
the bus service that I'm trying to map
out here let's say I have Jersey City
passed in here now I'm gonna have to
look for that stop if it exists in this
entire bus ecosystem so if it exists in
the bus routes if if it if there is any
kind of bus stop that has the name
Jersey City and then it will be returned
here so over here I go for each Loop and
it says over here the vertices a list so
I'd say for every vertex V if the value
so I'll use the get the data value and
this vertex remember that I created get
data over here somewhere so it's
supposed to be somewhere over here there
you go it returns a data stream and
if it equals to the value that was
passed it as an input over here then
we'll return the V vertex and then
you'll have it as a Vertex here so
perfect and if it didn't exist it would
just return null so that will help us
know if the vertex exists here or not
and now over here if you want to print
it so for vertex V in this dot vertices
B dot print and we have is waiter so you
know the print method that we created
here this will allow us to see all of
these vertices in action awesome now
let's create the main deal here let's uh
create some graph let's create the graph
data structure and let's try to map it
out
and I'm gonna remember I said I'm gonna
create a bus station so I'm gonna say
g-r-a-p-h
and I'm gonna say
um bus Network
and I'm gonna say new graph
[Applause]
and over here we're gonna pass in
for the is weighted and for the director
thing we're gonna pass in both true true
so t-r-u-e and t-r-u-e now let me tell
you why I did this the first one was
input is weighted so it is weighted
there's going to be values Associated to
it so for every Edge there's going to be
some kind of a distance and the input is
directed meaning that there's going to
be some kind of Arrow and uh it's so
it's a it's not bi-directional it's not
two ways it's just one way going forward
so bus Network
and I'm going to use the add vertex
method that we created here in this
method so it asks us for a string data
and we'll just say
um let's say Clifton
and here we have it semicolon but
remember that this add vertex method if
you go
if you go and see the method here it's
actually returning a Vertex so we're
gonna have to store in some kind of
variable so let's store it in a vertex
and I'll call this as
cliff
Clifton station
[Applause]
and it equals to that so there you go
and the same goes for the next one so
I'll say bus Network
dot add vertex
and we'll say vertex
and over here we'll have um the next
station and I'll just add a Cape May
station
and uh
let's have the vertex here as well so
vertex and I'll say
Cape um
keep me
station
and just there you go so we created two
stops and I think that's enough for now
so now what we have to do is add the
edges and the connections between them
so we use the you know the add edge
method
so we'll use bus Network
and we'll say add edge
and to add edge we have to put one
station to the next so we'll take
Clifton station and we'll say the Cape
May station
so that's um the connection and we'll
also have to put a weight we'll have to
put a weight as well so I'm gonna say it
takes 1 000 miles to reach there
and that's our weight cool now it's
connected
and remember that I'm not putting it uh
so I'm just putting it one way and it's
just gonna connect it
um that uh you know directed way
here we have
um that if I wanted to remove an edge it
would uh remove it using the same but
I'm just gonna say bustnetwork.remove
Edge and just pass in the same two
things not the weight that time in this
case I just want to print it out and see
how it looks like so bus Network the
print
and this is our method that was um
that is created here and actually
calling all the vertices so it's going
to be printing it through here awesome
so let's run this baby up and see how it
looks like so I'm gonna command prompt
here and I'm gonna say Java C the name
of it is called graph
.java
it compiled and now after that I'm just
gonna
[Applause]
paste here so over here we have the
direction from Clifton to Cape May and
it takes 1 000 miles so that's exactly
what we did here uh let me just minimize
it quickly and go back here and if I
look over here I actually created a
direction from Clifton to capeman it
takes 1 000 miles and I didn't do the
other way around like I said this was
not undirected it was directed because
it was such true and here you could see
that
um there's just one way from Clifton to
Cape May to 1000 and I can't go from
Cape May back to Clifton and if I want
to do that I could easily do that I
could just modify this so input is
weighted that's set to true if I just
leave this as nothing so
by default it would consider that as
false so all right so I'm just gonna
have to um if I add in false here and
that's just gonna make it undirected so
it's going to go both ways around and if
I do this now it's going to go
um bi-directionally so I'll say this and
then after that so over here we have
Clifton to Cape May 1000 and Cape May
back to Clifton 1000.
[Music]
using graphs to model complex networks
is great but Graph Search algorithms are
another way graphs can be useful a graph
search algorithm can be used to Traverse
the entire graph data structure in
search of a specific vertex value there
are two approaches to using a graph
search to navigate a graph DFS and BFS
DFS or depth first search follows every
possible path to its conclusion BFS on
the other hand or breadth first search
expands the search from the point of
origin to an ever-expanding circle of
neighboring vertices to track down what
we visited we add a list this list will
be very crucial because it prevents the
search from returning to the same vertex
multiple times this is especially
important for cyclical graphs where you
could otherwise end up in an infinite
Loop and we've seen this in our previous
videos so you might be wondering how
does one compute the runtime of graph
search algorithms in an upper bound
scenario we would examine every vertex
and Edge as a result the Big O run time
for depth first and breadth first search
is O of vertices plus edges so you have
the O and you have bracket vertices plus
edges now here's a question what if you
don't need to find a path but you do
need to find a list of all the values in
a graph what should be the solution
there well it turns out that in addition
to pathfinding Dev first search is
pretty Adept at organizing vertices
or vertex values with a clear order of
visitation from beginning to end so you
could use depth first search to find a
path you know like instead of
pathfinding but you go to organize and
show the layout of the complete graph
structure using depth for search there
are three main traversal orders that
you'll come across for graph traversal
pre-order post order and reverse post
order also known as topological sort
pre-order in which each vertex is added
to the visited list and added to the
output list before getting added to the
stack so that's just one thing to
remember here in post order in which
each vertex is added to the visited list
and added to the output list after it is
popped off of the stack and then reverse
post order which is also known as
topological sort which returns an output
list that is exactly the reverse of the
post order list so post order and
reverse pulse order are just like the
Opposites of each other here I have a
cool graphical representation of a graph
take a look at this directed graph
structure that I've depicted here let's
say that we want a list of all vertex
values starting with one in the order
that they are added to the stack now a
pre-order DFS traversal would come in
handy now over here we we assume that
the algorithm prefers visiting things in
numerical order if there is a choice so
our Target value is one and normally you
would get a Target value from the
program so our Target value is one here
so we're starting with one we'll go with
one so this is the first thing that's
visited this is also going to be on top
of the stack so over here if we have a
choice we're going to prefer visiting
the minimum number so over here we have
three and four we're going to check
three so we're gonna go and visit three
and we're also going to put it on top of
the stack over here after that we see
that there's four and two so we're going
to look at the smaller number and we're
gonna we're gonna visit it so two is
going to be over here two is also going
to be over here and then we're also
going to check fourth five so because
it's five and there's no other option so
we're gonna have to check five we'll put
we're on the stack as five over here and
the visited we'll go over here as well
now the important part came and you
could see that there's nothing after
this so we'll have to pop this thing out
of the stack so we're gonna have to I'll
just pop it out like this and now we'll
check two so two still has nothing
um with it so we'll pop that out as well
and then we'll check three so three has
something so it has
um thing that was not visited
um and it was four and it's not in the
visited set so we're gonna add that
um four over there so just add four to
the top of the stack here
and we're gonna add four here as well
now we're gonna check for the four and
we're gonna see well the four doesn't
have anything
so we're gonna pop that out on the stack
as well and then after that we have
three so we're looking at for three
something any number that is already uh
that is not visited so everything is
visited four and two are visited so
we're gonna remove three we're gonna
look at one if there's anything that is
not visited we'll have to check but
there's nothing everything is visited
three and four are there so we'll remove
that so this is how our list will appear
one three two five four so this is the
pre-order DFS traversal all right so
like I said that pre-order is is that
kind of order in which each vertex is
added to the visited list and add it to
the output list before getting added to
the stack so this was our pre-order
traversal now we want to look at post
order traversal in which each vertex is
added to the visited list and add it to
the output list after it is popped off
of the stack so uh if we look at take a
look at the post order traversal we'll
go like this so for the first thing it's
one so we're just going to look at one
we're not going to add it to the list or
anything yet then we're going to look at
the smaller number which is three
then we're going to look at something
even smaller than that which is two then
we're going to look at something uh and
then we have five so there you go the
last number came so it's gonna go like
this five
and then after that it's gonna go and
see the two because it's going to be
popped off as well so five two and then
we're gonna look at three so three
actually has something for this
so we're gonna have to add four
and then we have nothing over here so
four
and then we have
um back to three
so back to three and then we have
we have the last one which is one so
this is our post order traversal this is
how it's gonna appear and the reverse
post order which is also known as the
topological sword will return an output
list that is exactly the reverse of the
post order list so this is the post
order traversal and the exact opposite
of this is one
three four
two
and then five
so this here is the reverse post order
also known as the topological sword and
these are just different ways to
Traverse
the graph
the most common was the first one which
was pre-order and that's the default
thing and it's easy for us to just get a
full overview of the graphic like that
alright so let's have a conceptual
overview of how the depth first search
DFS is going to work so let's suppose we
have our Target value as one so we're
gonna go and visit one here and we're
also gonna put it on the stack so this
is the top of the stack then we'll have
to look at the number that is smaller
from the choice over here we got three
and four we're looking at a smaller
number and we'll put three on top of the
stack here and we'll put it as our
visited set as well so we have three and
then after that we look at the smaller
number from these two and the two is the
smaller number so we'll put it in the
visited set
and we'll also put in the DFS stack so
we'll put it up on the top over here and
now we can see that five is the only
option so we'll have to use five here as
we visited and then we'll have to put
five here on the top of the stack as
well since there's nothing over here on
this
um there's nothing after the five so
we're gonna have to pop this out so to
do this we're gonna have to just uh
select this number and just pop it out
and now we're gonna look at two so
there's nothing with two as well so
we're gonna have to pop this out
three has some unvisited vertex which is
this four one because it's not in the
set over there so we're just gonna have
to use this now so we're gonna use four
and we're gonna put it over here so four
is going to be over here and and four
will be on top of the stack as well now
we look at four because this is our
current Uh current vertex and there's
nothing over here that's uh unvisited so
we're gonna have to pop this out again
so let's just pop it out
so there you go so this is popped out
and now we look at three there's nothing
unvisited so we'll just pop this out
look at one and there's nothing
unvisited so we'll just pop that out
once the stack is complete from here so
it's empty we'll have a list over here
one three two five four and this is the
list of all of the vertices inside of
this entire graph so we have one three
two five and four this was our DFS depth
first search now let's write the code
for this so here I have a class graph
traverser and it has a main method and
also I have a sample graph that I've
created earlier and it just contains
some vertices and yeah it just has a
method here that says get starting
vertex and we'll get the first vertex
here
from the graph
now our job here is to write the code
for a depth first traversal reversals
are extremely useful when trying to find
a specific value or path in a graph
we'll start with the depth first
traversal method for recursively
traversing a directed graph to summarize
depth first reversals iterate down each
vertex one neighbor at a time in this
video I'll focus on traversing the
entire length of a single path and
printing the data value of each vertex
and now in test grab.java I've created a
sample graph for us to test the
traversals against this is all linked to
my last video about graphs so we created
a graph here and we have this input is
weighted as false and is directed as
true so there's no weight but it's
directed meaning it's it has directions
right and we have a Vertex start node
and we have test graph.ad vertex and we
have the name so these are the names of
our vertices and yeah so they're all
these vertices here now I have all of
these vertices that I added and then I
created these the variables to associate
to them and then after that what we did
is ADD edges so connections were done
after that we created a cycle here as
well and this is not exactly the same
graph that I've made on in the diagram
so which I have what I have here in the
diagram was just simple so that you
could easily understand how DFS works
but here I just created a complex one so
that we could test Out Cycles as well
and other things after that we have this
uh graphtiverser.java to keep things
simple I created a separate graph
traversal utility class in
graftaverser.java and I'll implement the
traversal iterator as a static method
here now I've seen implementations in
which they created the iterator inside
of the graph class so now let's start
writing the code here in the graph
traverser.java utility class we're gonna
first of all let's just add a method
that is for the depth first reversal so
we say in public and we say static
because it's a static method and void
and we're going to say depth first
because we're using a static method here
because this is a utility class so depth
first traversal
and here I'm just gonna pass in the
vertex to start with so
when I need the star vertex and also I
need a list of all the visited vertices
for this uh start one so that will be
called as an arraylist
and I'm gonna put in the
um vertex type here and we're also gonna
put in the name as visited and then we
have vertices cool so now we're done
with this let's add in the things here
first let's just print out the value of
our star data so we have a
system.out.print island and we say
um start dot get data so you might be
asking where do I get this get data from
um so I already have
vertex.java included here and I've
created this in my previous video so we
have a get data method and it just
Returns the string data now that we're
gonna have to iterate through this
vertex and we're gonna check its edges
so all of the edges for this start
vertex so we could use an edge edve of e
so for all the edges e in the start
um dot get edges so
this is also a method inside of the um
vertex class so over here I'm I'm saying
for every Edge inside of the start
um edges so this this means all of those
um all of those neighbors that are
connected right so we have to get the
neighbor vertex so to get that we're
going to use e dot get
end and this will give us a Vertex so
you can see that return gave us a vertex
and we could save it as a Vertex
um neighbor
n-e-i-g-h-b-o-r now one thing uh to note
here is that this e is an edge and the
get end is from The Edge class so this
is also here so get end is going to be
somewhere over here there you go and it
Returns the vertex end from there so
it's just pretty simple this one the end
vertex
now
um right after this I'm gonna have a
conditional here and I'm gonna check if
um
if my visited vertices does not contain
this thing so I'm gonna add it inside so
now we're gonna know and we could uh we
can mark that that we already visited or
not to keep track if we've visited
vertices or not we're going to add this
conditional so if we're gonna use
visited
vertices
and then we say dot contains
and then we have um the the neighbor and
I say if that contains inside of the
visited vertices because you know that
the visited vertices was passed here
and I'm saying if it's not inside of the
visitor vertices then we want to add it
so we'll just put a negation here and
let's also uh quickly add this import so
just over here and quick fix import the
arraylist as well on top okay cool now
over here in this inside the conditional
I'm going to add in the visited vertices
and I'm going to say dot add
and I'm going to add in the uh neighbor
vertex here so I'm going to say neighbor
since our visitor vertices holds a
vertices vertices and we could easily
add a Vertex here the really important
recursive call here is that we're gonna
do a recursive call that will go to the
graph traverser again so you're going to
call the graph traverser which is this
current class and we're going to call
the method which is um death first
reversal
and now it's requiring us a start and
visit so the visited vertices will be
the same thing but now we're going to go
with the neighbor so n e i g h b o r
okay so we're done with that and um the
conditional is done and here is the for
each Loop and it's going to iterate
through all of the edges uh for our
stride vertex and it's going to go until
it's done so that's pretty much it with
our depth first traversal we could test
it out in our main method we're going to
create a test graph
and we're gonna say task
and what we're going to say is new test
graph
okay so where am I creating this from
this is actually from this place and
this is just creating a test graph
remember like I said it created this
whenever this is a public test graph
Constructor and in the Constructor just
doing all of the work for us so normally
we would put this in a main method but
we're putting this in a Constructor so
it's creating a gigantic ginormous uh
kind of graph with so many vertices so
V1 V2 v11 V12 all these so one two three
four five six seven eight nine nine
vertices and they're connected edges and
What's it gonna do is it's gonna show us
uh through this so we're just gonna
create it here and we're gonna pass it
in so before that we actually need the
starting vertex of our test graph as
well and we had created this handy
method here which was get starting
vertex which returns us the first vertex
um in our graph so we could use test and
then we say get uh starting vertex and
this would uh just give us the starting
vertex and we go save it somewhere
inside because of return this actually
returns a Vertex type so we could say
vertex
and then we say
um starting vertex so we'll say starting
um vertex and we'll just equal it okay
cool so now that it's equal now we could
uh add in the visited vertices so now
let's add the visited vertices uh list
so array list and I'll put the type as a
vertex
and I'll call this as visited vertices
so visited vertices
and here we're gonna pass in a new array
list
and here we're gonna
um just instantiate it so
like that I guess semicolon at the end
so we created a visitor vertices array
list as well
and we're gonna add in the starting
vertex because it's already visited so
we're just gonna add it before all of
the operations and we'll just add in
starting vertex here cool now when it's
done we're done with this initial thing
now we can finally call our depth first
reversal so this thing and uh it's
really easy it's uh the name of the
graph uh traverser the depth first
traversal and it's asking us for the
start vertex as I would say starting
vertex and the visited vertices and this
should have printed out so let's go into
this uh place which is right here
and command prompt it here and let's go
down and let's say Java C and we say um
graph
traverser
Java
and now let's just run it so well
graph
trout first sir
so here we have the the way how this
will work that's pretty pretty dope now
it's time to focus on breadth first
traversal as a reminder the breadth
first traversal iterates through the
graphene layers it goes down one layer
which comprises the star vertex's direct
neighbors then it proceeds down to the
next layer which consists of all the
vertices that are neighbors of the
vertices in the previous layer and for
this example I'll focus on traversing
down one layer and then take a similar
approach as we did with the depth first
reversal by keeping an array of visited
vertices to prevent us from iterating
through the same vertices over and over
however we will iterate through all of
the direct neighbor vertices instead of
iterating down the neighbor's first Edge
like we did in depth first traversal we
will also use a q to Traverse through
the graph instead of recursion to
explore the different ways we can
implement the Traverse I'll reuse the
same test graph that was used in the
depth first traversal implementation all
right so what I have is a directed graph
and I'm gonna have to apply breadth
first traversal so what I'm going to do
is I'm going to get my target value
suppose we have it as one starting value
and I'm just going to put it in the
visited and I'm also going to put it in
our BFS Cube we're gonna look at our
adjacent vertices and see the smaller
number so here we have three and we're
going to choose that as the first one so
we're gonna say three as our visited
and we're also going to put three here
as well now that we've done that we look
at the other adjacent one which is four
and we're going to add that in our
visited set and we're also going to add
it here in our queue now that we've
exhausted our current vertex since there
are no more uninvisited vertices so
we're gonna have to remove this one from
our queue so we're gonna remove this one
and now three will be our new current
vertex and we'll look at the adjacent
ones here so we have two and four but
two is smaller so we're going to choose
two first and here we have two in the
visited and two in the queue now we also
have four but four is already visited
here so we're not going to look at that
now that we've done this we're gonna
have to uh since three is exhausted now
we're gonna have to remove that as well
so we're gonna DQ it
and we're gonna now look at four now
four is over here and there's nothing
that we could visit so we're gonna have
to remove this as well so we'll remove
four
and after that we could see
Tui is now our current vertex and two
has
a neighboring
a neighboring vertex which is five so
we'll put five here and it's the only uh
neighboring vertex so we'll just put the
bfsq over here so now that we've
exhausted two we'll remove it from there
as well
and five is also nothing so there's
nothing with five as well so that's
completely exhausted as well so here we
have completely visited the entire graph
using breadth first search one three
four two and five awesome now let's
write the code for this so I'm going to
the same file where I created my depth
first search and I'm going to add my
breadth first search right after this so
this is my uh depth first search and
right after this I'm gonna create my
breath first search so I'm going to say
public and we're also gonna make this as
a static method since this is a utility
class b r e a d e h f i r s t and then
SC search so first search so breadth
first search adding the vertex start
just like that and also the array
um list
which is the vertex
and this is going to be called the
visited vertices uh just like what we
did up on the top for our depth first
traversal now since you saw the
graphical implementation there I used a
cube so I'm going to create a queue here
as well so q and I'll call it visit Q
and here we're gonna equal it to New Q
so q u e u e and we're just going to put
that as well now you might be asking
where is the queue coming from well I
actually have the Q
file here as well so this is the
queue.java file and we've created cues
before but I actually modified it here a
little bit so the same exact queue that
we've created in our video series but I
just modified it a little bit just to
add vertex as the data now instead of a
string or some kind of integer
so removing that and now let's just go
here
and over here now we created our queue
it's called our visit Q
and we're gonna have the visit Q
dot NQ the first thing which is the
start which was passed in as the input
parameter and that's the vertex there
now we're adding a while loop and this
is going to go until the visit queue is
not empty so I'll say visit Q because
this is a queue it has this method which
is is empty and I've created that one so
I'll say if it's not empty we're gonna
go inside of this visit queue and keep
doing those removing uh Q things and you
know uh traversing and using breadth
first search there so for that I could
let's just get something down and
actually
DQ the the element in the queue so we
could say visit
so we could say visit Q Dot DQ
and here we have a Vertex that we have
to DQ so we'll put it inside of a
current variable so I'll say current
all right so now that it's in current we
could print out the value here as well
just say system
dot out
dot print
Ln and then we say
um you know current dot data and there's
a get data method that was in the vertex
class so there you go it's working there
now that we're using a for each Loop to
go through each of the edges inside of
this current vertex
because that's what I showed you in the
graphical implementation now I'm just
mapping all of the entire explanation
down in code so I'm saying Edge for
every edge of the current vertex so it's
a current dot get edges
which is the returning an array list of
edges and what we're going to do here is
that so now we're going to get the
neighboring vertex
of the current vertex to do that we
could easily get it from E dot get end
and that returns us a Vertex that's our
neighboring vertex
are we pass it in to this vertex a
variable and we'll call it as neighbor
and over here
[Applause]
will apply a conditional and we'll say
if the
um now since I'm using um a visited
vertices arraylist over here in my input
parameter that checks if uh something is
not repeated twice so I'm saying if it's
not existing so I'll say if visited
vertices
dot contains
and the neighbor thing n e i g h b o r
so I'm saying if it does not contain it
then you should add it so I'm saying if
it does not contain that neighbor vertex
then you should add it so we'll say
visited vertices dot add
and
so visitor vertices.add and then we'll
add in the neighbor
vertex
perfect and then the last thing that we
could do here because we created this
visit queue and we'll include this
inside of our visit queue so we'll just
say visit Cube dot NQ which is this and
we'll put in a Vertex data so we'll put
in that vertex which is the neighbor n e
i g h b o r so this will be inside of
our visit queue which is
um this queue and it just currently had
only the start but once when you get the
edge of the the neighboring vertex you
also pass that inside of the wizard
queue so that will be now the current
vertex and it will go until there's a
dead end and then we'll just
um remove from the enqueue and then so
once it's exhausted like you see over
here in this while loop so it's just
gonna say until it's empty not empty so
it's just going to keep going and once
it's exhausted like you can see over
here DQ so we'll just see the other
vertices that are there to Traverse
now let's go down in the main method and
just have everything over here set like
this so just pause the video and type
along and over here for the starting
vertex test dot starting vertex here we
have a arraylist Vertex visited vertices
the same thing and this is the same
exact thing so instead of depth first
traversal we're going to say
be our breadth first traversal and
the rest is history
I'm compiling it and running it let me
just label them as well so jump that out
Dot println
or really just have a line here so okay
and then we say it
DFS I would say b f s run this
[Applause]
so here you go the difference between
the two of the traversal techniques here
we have DFS at the other side we have
BFS so we have over here 0 1 1 and
something like that and then we have two
over here so something's going on
differently but if you look at the total
numbers one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten one two three four
five six seven eight nine and ten so the
total number should be ten it's there's
ten over here and there's 10 over here
and if we look at the test graph.java
here so the start node one two three
four five six seven eight nine and ten
awesome
so that was it that was my code for
depth first traversal
[Music]
welcome to another video today we're
going to be talking about dijkstra's
algorithm a very important algorithm in
the computer science World finding the
shortest distance between vertices is
one of the most common applications of
graph searches finding this distance has
a number of applications including
determining the best route to a
destination and transferring data over a
computer network consider the graph
finding the shortest path between vertex
a to vertex e may appear simple in your
mind but telling a computer how to do so
is a bit more difficult fortunately
there is an algorithm that computes the
shortest distance between any two
vertices in a graph this is known as
dijkstra's algorithm now let's look at
the conceptual overview of how the
dijkstra's algorithm is going to work
we're going to start with the starting
vertex and you can see that the start is
pointing to a so this is my target
vertex here I have a distances Cube and
I also have this unvisited which is in
the bottom now I'm going to look at the
first step here in this algorithm and
the first step is to pop off the minimum
distance of the unvisited vertices now
you can see over here the minimum
distance here is zero and these rest are
all set to Infinity meaning that the
distance from a to itself is zero and
the distance from a to any of one of
these vertices is infinity for now and
if we look at the minimum distance right
now it's zero zero so we're going to pop
this off so we're gonna pop it off from
here and then we're gonna look at the
adjacent vertices corresponding to this
first vertex so you can see over here so
from A to B the distance is four now if
you compare this with the original
distance which is infinity now 4 is less
than infinity so we can replace this
Infinity with four since we replace that
now we could also go and check the next
corresponding distance now a to c has a
weight of two now you could see that two
is less than the Infinity the so we
could also replace this Infinity with
two
now we're done with that and we're gonna
this is our first iteration of the
algorithm now we're going to go to the
next iteration so now we're going to pop
off the minimum distance of the
unvisited vertices and you can see for
now we could see that 2 which is for C
is the minimum vertices we're going to
pop that out from here and we're going
to start with C so you can see C has
um at a c only has one neighbor and that
is e and the distance from uh C to e is
one and you have to look at the distance
from a to C2 so the A to Z was two and
from C to e was one the total distance
from a to e is three so two plus one is
three so what we're going to do here is
we're gonna make from a to e as three
and then we're going to look at the E
portion and we're going to see that uh 3
is less than infinity so we're going to
replace this Infinity with three now
since there's no more neighbors left
we're going to do the next iteration for
this algorithm so you guys know more
neighbors so now we're going to pop up
the minimum distance of the unvisited
vertices you can see now that the
minimum distance is three so it's in E
so we're going to pop this off and we're
gonna go to E I look at the
the neighbors for each so e has only one
neighbor and that is D the weight for
that is five the distance will be three
plus five which is eight and eight is
less than infinity so we can replace
this Infinity with eight now that we
have replaced that we can also uh see
that there's no more corresponding
vertices so we could we could stop here
and do the next iteration for the
algorithm now we're gonna pop up the
minimum distance of the unvisited
vertices so you can see that the minimum
distance is B so we're gonna pop this
off
and over here we're going to look at the
corresponding neighbors now B has one
two and three corresponding neighbors
we're going to start with the first one
which is C so B to C is one and now you
can see now from A to B which was
already existing was four and from there
to C it's
one so five so from a to c will be five
and if we look at the uh see uh it
already exists here and and you can see
five is greater than two so we're not
going to change this value then we're
going to look at the distance from B to
e and that's three so from A to B it's
four and from there to e it's seven so
if we look at the distance from a to e
that should be seven and that is greater
than the value that we already have here
so we're not going to change that at all
either now we're going to look at the
last and final neighbor of B and that is
D now if we look at the weight this is
two and the distance from here was four
two so it's going to be from A to B it's
four and from B to D it's going to be
two so the total distance here from a to
d will be six and if we look at the
distance over here that is actually
lesser than what we have existing so we
could replace this eight with six and
that now will be the the end of our
iteration and now we'll go to the next
iteration of our algorithm now we're
going to try to pop off the minimum
distance of the unvisited vertices since
we only have one vertices left which is
D and we look at the minimum distance
here and that is the minimum distance
rest everything has been visited so
that's D so we're going to try to we're
going to pop it off and we look try to
look at any neighbors for D but there's
nothing so that's the end of our
algorithm there and that's how
dijkstra's algorithm is implemented so
you went over there and saw all of the
possible distances so from a to itself
the minimum distance is zero from A to B
the minimum distance is four till here
from a to c the minimum distance is two
right here from a to d the minimum
distance is six so four two till here
and from a to e the minimum distance is
three so a to e is the minimum distance
is three
so that sums up our Dexter's algorithm
conceptual overview now we're gonna
start writing the code for this but
before getting on to the code let's
think of what we should add in or we
want objects and what structures should
we create looking into this algorithm
we're going to instantiate a dictionary
that will eventually map vertices to
their distance from the start vertex so
like you can see over here we're going
to put that in a dictionary a quick
recap before we start the code for this
dijkstra's algorithm finds all of the
shortest distances between a starting
vertex and the remaining vertices in a
graph the algorithm operates by keeping
track of all distances and updating them
as it performs a breadth first search
dijkstra's algorithm is implemented in O
of e plus v of log of v and e means
edges and V means vertices we will first
implement the algorithm to find the
shortest distance to every vertex so
let's go for the code and all of the
conceptual overview that I gave now I'm
going to try to map this out in code so
here I have imported
java.util.ast meaning I'm importing
everything that's available in the
utility package and of it over here that
you can see is public class dijkstra and
there I have a main method here I have a
main method which is actually creating a
test graph and the weighted and directed
properties are set to true and we also
add these vertices here so a b c d e f g
also add their connections to each other
so those are done
so what we mainly have here is a test
graph in our main method to test the
output of the method of what we're going
to create in this video so we're going
to try to create that method which is
called dijkstra's so for that we're
going to have the public
and we're going to say static
dictionary
and we put in this so we're going to
return an array of dictionaries and I'll
tell you why we're doing this
in just a sec so here we have the name
of the algorithm dijkstra and we're
going to tell the parameter to add in
these two values first thing is to have
the graph so d r a p h and we call that
as G we also need to pass in a vertex
and that will be will be called as
starting vertex
so we're done with these two input
parameters now we're going to create two
dictionary objects here
and one will be used for the distances Q
the other one will be used to keep track
of your previous vertex and this is very
crucial in this algorithm
I'm just going to make a dictionary and
a dictionary is just a base of key value
pairs
we have a string which is the key
and integer as the value
and we call this as distances
and we created new hash table
and we put in these angle brackets and
the round brackets and then we semicolon
at the end
so that's the distance is Q now we also
need another hash table
and this one will be for the previous
so we
add this as well
and for this we're not going to have the
integer as the value but the vertex
this is going to store the
data and the also value that it exists
so like I was doing it over there in the
diagram this a and it Maps out to zero
and this B that Maps out to four so the
string is the letter and the value is
going to be the integer and for the
second dictionary which is previous it's
going to keep track of the previous
vertex so that will have a string which
is the current vertex and vertex will be
the previous now we also need to add in
a priority Cube so I have a added some
files here and this is a one that's
called Q object.java This is actually a
class that implements the comparable Q
object and you can see that it has the
vertex and the priority as class
variables and you can see the uh the
Constructor is actually creating this
object and it's overriding the
comparator method with uh some priority
base so if it's equal in priority to the
input parameter we just return zero if
the class variable priority is greater
than the priority that was passed in
then we will return one else we will
return minus one so this is just a
uh just a file and it's just a fancy
queue it's just known as a priority
queue the main difference between this
queue and the priority queue is that
this will look at the smallest value
smallest possible value and it will
allow us to pop that one off so like
what we're trying to do here we were
trying to look at the minimum value and
we're trying to pop that off that exact
implementation is priority queue will do
it for us without writing extra code so
that's one of the biggest benefits for
using that so let's add the priority
queue and this is the priority queue so
priority queue and we're gonna add in
the few objects here so q-u-e-we and
we're gonna say object that we created
and then we could add the name for that
as q q u e u e is equal to now we're
gonna add in the new and it will say
priority queue
and here we're just gonna
add in the Q object once more
and then the semicolon at the end
perfect so this is our priority queue
created and I'm just add in the same
exact line so just after that now you
might be asking well the priority queue
is actually empty right now we gotta cue
something inside
now the thing that we're going to queue
inside
for the first thing is the starting
vertex since we know the distance for
that is zero to itself so we're just
going to cue that up in here it's going
to say q-u-e-u-e dot add
and here we're just going to say New Q
object
and we're gonna pass in
the vertex V and the int P which is a
priority the vertex V is just going to
be the starting vertex and the priority
for this would be zero
awesome
now we're going to try to iterate
through this entire graph that was
passed in as an input parameter and
we're going to try to iterate through
and try to find all the vertices here so
we could use a for each Loop for this
purpose and we could say for every
vertex V
so we can say for every vertex V in the
g dot get vertices and this is returning
an arraylist of vertex and you just uh
doing this really easily and this is
also added here so I have a graph.java
file and this is also added so that's
why I'm able to get the method get
vertices so
this is uh get vertices and it should be
over here somewhere
you have vertices so this is the get
vertices method and I'm also adding this
as well as this vertex.java you could
look at my older videos and from there
I'm actually using all of those classes
that I've created in the graph.java the
vertex.java and the edge.java we're all
done in a single video which was called
graphs in Java so watch that video and
for this Q object uh I'm just gonna let
you see this code for uh no you could
just pause the video and copy this and
once you have all of these we could go
back here in the dijkstra.java and we're
just going to iterate through the
vertices which are in this graph which
was passed in as an input parameter now
we're going to have to iterate through
this and we're going to actually update
our distances
which was over here so we're gonna
actually have to update our distances
and previous dictionaries so we're going
to try to add all these vertices from
this graph to this distances and
previous dictionaries we could do
um first of all we don't want the
starting vertex to have a maximum
integer of max value because we know
that the starting vertex to itself is
zero so we're going to give a condition
here and say if the vertex you get is
the starting vertex
and this is just going to work so we're
going to say if that one is the starting
vertex
we don't want that so if it's not right
so we want to update the distances and
we're gonna have to add and put this is
a method available in the dictionary and
this is this allows us to add a key and
value pair so the string is the key and
the value is the integer so what we
could do here is for the string we could
say V which is the vertex and we say got
dot get
um
so we could say get data and that would
return a string here and this is also
added in the vertex.java so that's why
it's working here and for the integer we
could just add in the maximum or we want
to use the infinity symbol right we
could use integer.max value this would
give us the maximum value for the
integer and Java and that will be stored
inside of the value pair so key values
are done and for the other case where we
have the previous dictionary so we'll
say previous say previous dot put and
for this second dictionary we'll also
have a key value pair but the value is a
vertex so the key is going to be the get
data the same thing
but for the value in this case will be
the previous vertex so that we could
keep track of this so we're just going
to add in a Vertex that will be set to
null for now and then after that we're
going to update it inside of our code so
right now just set everything to node
I'm including the starting vertex
all right so right after this
um we needed to add in the starting
vertex here in our distances because we
don't have it so to do that we'll just
add in the distances again
I will say put and now we want to add in
the key value pair for that and for this
add in the starting vertex and we
actually need the value for this and we
could say get data and that would give
us the string data and for the value I'm
not going to give the maximum value
we're not going to give Infinity because
if we look at this code over here
initially it was set to zero so we want
to just set it to zero here I'll put it
there
and there you go so we created this
entire thing what you can see over here
so you can see this entire thing that
we've created which has a set to zero
and the rest are all set to the infinity
or the max value
now let's go back
and we're gonna actually do the second
step for this
algorithm now it's the fun part we're
gonna have to iterate through the while
loop and we're gonna check if the Q is
not empty so we say q-u-e-u-e
this this is our priority View and we
say the size method here and if we say
if that size is not equal to zero
we're gonna do some operations inside of
this queue first of all we're gonna get
the current vertex here and that is
pretty simple Q Dot
poll retrieves and removes the head of
this queue or returns null if this queue
is empty so we're gonna actually remove
an item from the queue using this method
and we want the vertex here so we just
Pat say the vertex because we had
this over here as this Q object we
wanted the vertex here so we're removing
that from the priority queue so the
first thing will just be the starting
vertex and that was added in our queue
so
this was added over here Cuda add new
object starting vertex with the value at
zero so that one zero was actually it's
a value uh to itself so this is now set
to current
and we removed it from the queue perfect
now we're going to iterate through this
current variable which is the starting
vertex so we're going to look at all of
the edges or the neighbor is right here
that we say for every Edge e
and reset
mapping out to the current dot get edges
which is the array list returning of
edges so for every edges or every
neighbor's inside of this uh current so
every Edge and Edge contains vertices
remember
so
we're actually going to first look at
the value of what the edge is giving us
remember like I did in this first one
that we were looking at the values and
we're also judging inside of our
distances so we looked at let's say four
uh for the distance to D we had some
already included distance was two one
five which is eight so that was already
passed in but we also want to keep track
of the newer one so this is like four
two which is six and now this is an
alternative one we have to add that
somewhere and then we have to judge
something like if it's less than the um
original one then we could replace it so
we won't have an alternative and we want
to also have the original so for the
alternative case We'll add in an integer
and I'll say alternative
and I could add um the distances here so
distances and this is the distances
dictionary and I'll get the current
dot get data
and that is the string
and we also want the plus to the
Eda get weight so we're gonna get the
weight at the end
so this is the distance from the current
distance of the variable and the edge
distance so what this means is whatever
the distance
um is existing for this current now get
data the starting vertex is actually
zero to the distance where it's leading
to with its vertex so the edge where
it's leading to with its Edge this makes
sense because
this is um zero to itself but if we're
moving forward we have an edge with it
and we have some weight so we're adding
that weight as well so get weight
that's the alternative and we also need
a reference to our string neighbor
variable so we're going to add that as
n-e-i-g-h
or
so this is our neighbor value
and we just have to keep it uh
just keep it inside so we can say e dot
get end so this is the end vertex
and we want the value for this so we
have e dot end and we have get data
so over here it's pretty simple we have
a neighbor value and we want to have the
edge vertex
so we want to have the edge and we want
to get the end so we're going to get the
vertex through this and to get the data
we just say this so we're going to get
the vertex through this get end and
we're going to get the data so that
string is actually stored in the
neighbor value
now that the string is stored we could
use a conditional here to check if the
alternative value is lesser than the
original value so what we're going to do
here is pretty simple we'll say
alternative
is less than the distances
and we want the dictionary so this is
the distances.get and we want to get the
value for this we could just use the
neighbor value so that's why I stored it
over there so that we could get the
value of their neighbor value the
alternative value is less than our
neighbor value so what we're going to do
is that neighbor value is actually the
original distance that was stored inside
of our distances object which is on top
so over here we have distances if that
is possible we're just trying to
override it and so we're going to say
distance is about put
and we're going to get the neighbor
value so that exact neighbor value but
we're going to change it the value to
the alternative so we're gonna get the
key and the value so this is the string
neighbor value and then the integer will
be now the alternative distance
also we're going to have to modify our
previous so we're gonna have to add in
the neighbor value as well
so so for the neighbor value we actually
need the previous reference and the
previous reference will now be for our
current instance but the current one
which is now which is actually starting
vertex will be the previous vertex for
our neighbor value which is the current
one over here so it's just gonna keep
iterating this and updating our previous
reference
and the last thing what we want to do is
we want to add the neighboring value to
our Cube new q u e u e object and we
have to add in the vertex here so we're
going to say e dot get end so that's
gonna give us the vertex here
and to get the priority we could say the
distances structure dot get and to get
the
um value I'm just going to add in
neighbor value and that will give us the
value so this is the neighbor value is
the key and it will give us the value
which is associated to this key and that
will be updated to our queue and that's
going to be our priority so that will be
uh added and once it's done we're
actually going to break out from this
for Loop when all of these edges are
done and that will be updated and after
that until the while size is not less
than zero so this is just the line that
will pop off the minimum distance of the
unvisited vertex and the rest is history
over here what you saw all in the
conceptional overview everything is
happening and adjusting
and uh the right at the end so
when the while loop breaks so the dice
Dexter is requiring us to return a
dictionary array right so we want to
return that so over here right after the
while loop we could return
a new dictionary
and oh
so over here we're going to return a new
b-i-c-t-i-o-n-a-r-y and we're gonna get
this oil bracket over here which is the
array for this dictionary and this is
the array of the dictionary and we want
to pass in the distances distances with
the previous
structure here this is the return
statement we're going to return a new
dictionary and it will have the
distances and the previous dictionaries
so we'll have both the distances and
previous dictionaries inside of this
dictionary array which is returning here
in our function so we can hear that
dictionary array is returning so this is
the return statement at the end and uh
yeah so that was pretty much it with
this function
uh this is minimizing it so that you can
see the entire thing so this is the
entire method for extra now we also have
this helper method on this bottom so I'm
just going to paste this in
this is called the Dykstra Resort
printer method and what it accepts is an
array of dictionaries wow how convenient
we're just gonna use this entire thing
and it's going to return it and so we
can pass it inside of this and this will
just actually print all the distances so
what you can see over here so it's going
to print out the updated distances like
this and it's also going to print out
the previous positions so you're going
to see that as well so since these both
were dictionaries we're going to use
integration as keys to get the values of
all of this and it's just going to give
us the key and value Pairs and it's
going to be pretty cool so these both
are going to be allowing us to print
these structures so we're going to add
this process here so let's just create
this call so we I had this test graph
and what we want to do is we want to use
this method here which is dijkstra so to
use this we have to pass that inside so
we're going to use dijkstra here I want
to pass in the test graph
also going to pass in the starting
vertex and that is a because over here
is the first vertex and that's going to
be our starting vertex you could set
anything you want later on and then
after that we're actually calling this
inside of this method which is Dexter
result printer
since it's accepting a dictionary array
of D so I'm going to paste this thing
inside and we're gonna wrap it around
the Dykstra
so there you go and this will just print
out the things so cool so now let's run
this code so let's go and
add in CMD here
and let's run this code so Java c d i j
k s t r a DOT Java
and then let's just run it using Java
dij
k s t r a
all right so we have um an error here
something no pointer exception okay I
want the shortest path between two
vertices to calculate that we'll just
create a new method here
and we'll call this as public static
void and we'll call this as shortest
path between
inside here we'll have a graph bra pH
and we'll call it as graph G
we're also going to have the vertex and
we're going to get the starting vertex
and we also need the targeted vertex so
we're going to say
Target architects
here we have the shortest path between
method in which we're gonna input the
graph the starting vertex and the
targeted vertex because we want the
minimum distance between two vertices so
we're going to use this method for that
case we're gonna have the dictionary
array object here and we're going to
call this as d dijkstros
dictionaries
and that will be equal to
the dictionaries so we're going to call
the director method here we're going to
call it using the graph and the starting
vertex what actually it gives us is the
distances and the previous dictionaries
and I'm getting a error here it's
actually d i j
the method dijkstra is defined for
undefined for the type dijkstra so the
reason why I'm getting an error here is
because I don't have a k so d i j k and
if I do that I'm all set
now we want to put the distances and
previous in their own variables so we're
going to have the scope for that so I'm
going to say
distances dictionary
and it will contain all the values which
we had and then we're going to
manipulate this so we're going to say
dictionaries uh so dijkstra d i j k
s t r a and we have the extra
dictionaries and we have this Sub Zero
that will contain our distance
and for the second one
and for the second one we could have
that as one and that will be our
previous
awesome to get the distance of our
Target vertex we're going to say
distances
docket and we need to get the target
vertex
and we want the value for that we can
say get data that will return a string
and that would actually map us the value
from our distances which will be
something like uh you know the value
what it will take for us to reach from a
to that point
and that we could store in some variable
called
distance
so make sure you have the typeset to
integer here
and then that should go away
now what we want to do here is we want a
print screen that will just show us the
shortest distance path between those two
so what we could do is we could paste
this in and this is just going to print
out the shortest distance between the
starting vertex get data and the target
vertex.getdata
so just between the two vertex this is
just going to give us the um the letters
you know the distance between a to
whatever
and
system.out.println will just print us
the distance
which was inside of the target vertex
now we actually need the
um the generated path that we should
follow
to create the path we could create an
array list for us
and that would be of type vertex
and we're gonna call that as path we
initialized an array list to get the
target vertex and assign it to a
variable
is very important here so we're gonna
have Target vertex and assign it to a
variable so we're gonna go from the
target vertex to the starting vertex
it's a bit like the reverse link list so
we're going to use some kind of
functionality like that we're going to
use a while loop and we say while the v
the vertex
so if the V is data and the get data
will pass in a string I'll say if that
is not
no because we know that the first one
which is the starter wheel is no we're
gonna add in the path so the path is
actually the arraylist we're gonna say
the path dot add we're gonna add a zero
here because the path is actually making
us add something inside of this so we're
going to add in a zero
and this would mean that it will be
popped in the forward Direction it's not
going to go backwards it's not going to
queue
um there but every time a new value
exists it will come in the beginning
every time a new value is added to this
arraylist it will be added in the
beginning
so all right path.ad zero will be added
so every value will be added to the
beginning of the queue
not the end and the other thing that we
want to do is we want to pass in that V
so that vertex that we set up will be
also passed in here and then the next
step here is to
um get the previous instance here so we
could say previous structure which is a
dictionary dot get
and what we need is the data here so we
say B dot get
data
and that would give us a string uh
previous dot get and we got the value
over here and we're going to assign that
to the vertex so since we have that get
process here we could actually need the
vertex here
and that will assign to the vertex so
it's just going to keep going like that
and after this while loop we could just
print out system.out up here in the
shortest path
and what we have now is the shortest
path as well so we could go from vertex
path vertex From the Path structure
which is over here somewhere so vertex
path vertex so so we have this path
which is this entire array list that now
contains all of the vertices for that
directed path now all we're going to do
is iterate through this for every path
vertex we're gonna print path
vertex.getdata and that would just print
us the letters of the corresponding path
now the only thing that I'm going to do
now is like I said I called
dijkstra.dykstra result printer and I
passed in these two
so what I happened here was that I was
on an error and whenever I was running
this code I was getting this error over
here at line number 26 and 94. so over
here at night number 26 and 94 it
doesn't give me any clue of what's
happening but you could tell that
alternative is less than distances that
that get dimmer value so I was looking
at the alternative value very carefully
here I noticed that I did get an error
while I was doing this so This is
actually a syntactical error I was
trying to get the alternative path
distance and I was getting the value
from the distances dictionary and I
wanted to current.getdata and this is
what's gonna this was gonna actually
give us the value for this one so
I didn't need this parentheses over here
I actually needed that closed here
and now it was just going to give us the
value here which was string so it was
going to give us the value of that uh
current data so it's just going to be an
integer here and then that was going to
be added with the edge dot get weight so
that will also be an in so both of these
ins added
will result in this alternative value so
now it's proper and if I run the code
now
[Applause]
you can see now that this created it for
me so here what I had was these vertices
one two three four five six seven
vertices and these were the connections
to them I just called the diagram
methane passed in the test graph and put
it in the starting vertex after that I
use the shortest path between method and
this is all showing up pretty cool
foreign
the distance is is updated and it's
according to what these vertices are so
these are I believe seven vertices and
over here we have the connections to
them so you can see a is connected C A
is connected to B A is connected to D
and what you can see over here is that
the previous here we have a as null and
the rest when I said a is connected to b
d and c if we look at b d and c they're
all connected to a so D is connected to
a so over here you can see that this is
the structure here where we have all
these vertices and their corresponding
values so these are all the values that
have been updated so the distance from a
to itself is zero the distance from a to
G is minus 38 the distance from a to F
to 30 uh 20 so we just passed in these
values here and it just allowed us to
get the minimum distance from this graph
so just telling if the distance from A
to B is so so the minimum distance from
A to B is three the minimum distance
from a to d is four and so on over here
in the previous we have a has a previous
of null but the rest vertices show their
previous vertex as well for the last
method that we created we want to call
that shortest path between test graph
and we look at the starting vertex and
the target
now we want the path shown and also the
shortest path so what we can do is short
pass we pass an A and G and this is
going to call this method over here
which is going to call that method and
it will return us some cool looking path
here
so we'll
we'll clear the screen and then run it
and then see the shortest path here we
got the shortest distance from a to G
which is correct we got a to G and was
minus 38 the shortest path and it showed
how it was working here so a to d to e
to G so if we map this out and draw this
in a diagram or if we look at it
everything will be correct according to
these results and that actually sums up
our video
foreign